you should know the process make change
Todd that we can him oh no what did you
do to him exactly I've been able to get
a clear answer Oh another thing because
you understand what we're saying I mean
to the extent that you have understood
complete sentences in the first place he
understands well enough order your man
to step aside other would be violence
did you find it
hey youtubers is Charlie today we are
going to destroy the mountain it's not
as hard as you think but just careful
for spoilers for everything that's
happened on the show so far there's a
new round of the game of Thrones book
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so surprisingly as invincible as
he seems there's a lot of different ways
to get rid of the zombified Mountain
it's just that it's much harder now that
he doesn't feel pain the show's been
very vague about what Qyburn actually
did to him but the characters in the
books talked about him in roundabout
ways so you learn a little bit about the
peculiarities of what goes on when he's
not walking around next to Cersei we
learn from the other members of the
Kingsguard that he never eats he never
sleeps and he doesn't feel pain really
almost everything else about him other
than being extremely compliant because
he'll do whatever Cersei says is the
exact same as he was before one of the
biggest changes from the TV show to the
books and this could just be something
that we see in Windsor winter is that in
the books he never takes his helmet off
you see Cersei leave him with septa
nella to just abuse her it's implied
that he's going to do awful awful things
to her the problem with that other than
him just being an awful awful person is
that if Cersei didn't write a list of
things that she wanted him to do exactly
to septa unella I want you to do this
then this then this which she did not do
she just left him with her that means
that he actually has desires of his own
in the books that's implied he's more of
a straight-up zombie that just stands
there and waits for commands more like a
golem there's even that scene early in
season 6 where he goes back seeking
retribution for the slight against
Cersei and kills that person so it's
just more evidence that TV show
zombie mountain is just as smart as he
was before he became a zombie but what
Qyburn did essentially was removed a lot
of his internal organs replaced his
blood with something that would help
preserve him and presumably did
something to his brain that would make
him more compliant and open to commands
from Cersei or anyone else but that's
also probably part of the conditioning
the Qyburn gave to him you're only going
to listen to Cersei otherwise he'd be
compliant for anyone so if you're going
to defeat him in combat you still have
to be very quick
number five there's the old-fashioned
way just like Oberyn Martell who did
best him in combat but
as of his revenge mission succumb to
long monologuing enabling the mountain
to get the better of him and smash his
head so the easiest way to defeat him in
single combat is to use a weapon that as
long as oberyn martell you would also
have to have an extremely potent
neurotoxin and get him in the head
because a lot of his internal organs
have been removed so a lot of the
poisons that oberyn martell used to
poison him to paralyze him wouldn't work
as well on the zombie Mountain he
doesn't feel pain and it's implied that
he would just keep going no matter how
many times you stabbed him so you would
definitely have to use something to shut
his brain down because that's one of the
few things in his body that's still
working but there are very few people in
Westeros that are as good a fighter
especially with long weapons like that
is over in Martel so you're not going to
find anyone just sitting around that
could take him on a single combat
which is why Cersei was so confident
when she said that he was going to be
her champion that was what that whole
Tommen twist was about with the faith
getting him as king to declare that they
would not allow a trial by combat so
their big solution for defeating the
mountain was to remove him from the
equation the only way to win sometimes
is to not try but the next easiest way
would be to just get a giant mob of
people serving him at the same time in
ripping his limbs apart just like the
Joffrey mob during season two the big
fat High Septon he got ripped apart limb
from limb by the Joffrey mob so you
definitely would have to separate the
mountains head from his body otherwise
he would just keep going he wouldn't be
able to mow down every single peasant in
King's Landing so if you had a crowd big
enough and they all attacked him at the
same time he would be able to slow him
down and they would be able to separate
his head from his body
I love the parallels between the crowd
rising up and hating Joffrey in them
hating Cersei as well but of all the
ways that Cersei could go if they're not
going to do the Balon car it'd be a big
disappointment it would also be
wonderfully poetic justice to see her
ripped apart by her subjects but I think
we all have a very specific end in mind
for her mostly being killed by Jaime in
a parallel of the Kingslayer moment but
the next big way to kill the mountain is
Dragon Fire he could actually be eaten
by a dragon but the problem is is that
they'd have to grow quite a bit to fit
him down their gullet typically
I guess don't eat meat that hasn't been
charred that was what that scene during
season 4 with a goat herder son was all
about like he was just minding his own
business
drogon was coming for the goats so if
Daenerys could fly one of the dragons
close enough they could char the
mountain then take him down but the
problem with that is that Ragle and
Viserion or smaller dragons the mountain
could probably grab one of their necks
and crushed some of their bones before
he was taken down that's why it's so
important that you not get in close and
allow him to get his hands around you
that was Oberyn Martell downfall as he
got in close the mountain got on top of
them and that was the end of it but the
next big way this is actually a little
bit easier is wildfire wildfire will
just burn through so as long as you have
enough you could just douse him in it
it'll just burn him to ashes a may -
everybody in the great steps although
that was really more of an explosion but
you could do it either way you could
blow him apart or you could burn him to
cinders with wildfire as long as you
could find some more there is evidence
that there are caches of wildfire hidden
by the alchemists guild all beneath
King's Landing all over the place but
the way Qyburn was talking to Cersei
before the finale last season is that he
found a lot of it he didn't say that he
found everything but that doesn't mean
that it's all gone and the alchemists
guild could always make more it just
takes time in it Circe's greatest weapon
now after the Dragons died wildfire was
the key to the Targaryen power and we
have been perfecting it since the days
of maegor and essential oil sister
commanded us to do so so if you want to
know one of the ways that she could take
down one of the nurses dragon so I
actually do a video about this for
dragons like how to defeat dragons she
could use wildfire as long as more was
available because dragons arm you to
fire but wildfire is something different
all together but the last big way to
defeat the mountain would be to get his
brother Sandor Clegane the hound so I
know everybody wants to see cleganebowl
2.0 the problem with that is that you
look at these preview photos for Season
seven it looks like the mountain is
traveling with the Brotherhood to the
frozen north and it sounds like his
important storylines are going to take
place up there so he's going to be a
long ways away from the mountain so if
there is any Clegane Bowl to be had if
the mountain survives to season eight
the Hound survives to season eight
that's probably when it would happen but
we haven't seen a trailer yet so we'll
see if we see the characters in King's
Landing if the Hound is anywhere near
King's Landing then you can start laying
your bets on cleganebowl but really the
thing that the Hound has on other
fighters who would bite the mountain is
it as his brother he knows all of his
secrets he knows how he bites he knows
how he thinks in the evidence the show
has provided has shown that the mountain
still thinks a lot like he did before he
became a zombie it's just that he's very
open to suggestions by Cersei so
hopefully that explains some of the
easiest ways to defeat the mountain but
obviously if it's going to be one of the
single combat ways that you take him
down it's going to have to be someone
very special or very good with long
weapons and very strong neurotoxin
poison so let me know in the comments
how do you think that they'll defeat the
mountain in season 7 or season 8 however
long he survived do you think it's going
to be single combat what do you think
it's going to be one of the more
visually spectacular ways like Dragon
Fire or wildfire most of the times the
biggest villains on the show get the
most poetic endings like ramsay being
eaten by his hounds so just think in
that direction but what's going to
happen tonight is there's a whole bunch
of trailers posting a game of Thrones
trailer is just around the corner
probably in the next couple of weeks
because we're almost within the two
month window and that's really when they
start dropping new footage so it's not
going to be that long we're almost there
congratulations to lava dog you're the
winner of the last giveaway please
private message me so I can get your
contact details while you wait for all
that stuff to post tonight click here to
learn all about the Game of Thrones
spin-offs as they might be doing there's
four and you can click here for all my
season 7 promo
thank you so much for watching let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you